entrez bien garder devant la pyramide du
Louvre impossible de visiter le musée
bloqué ce matin par le personnel en
grève au dossier chaud des retraites
c'est à jour la colère contre les méga
bassines ce week-end intervention de la
police elle se fait toujours dans un
contexte de violence puisque pour
intervenir il faut attendre
en effet parce que dans un état droit on
ne peut interpeller des personnes on
n'est pas dans Minority reporte le
trentenaire est dans le coma deux autres
manifestants ont été grièvement blessés
au total 47 gendarmes ont par ailleurs
aussi étaient blessés ce n'est donc pas
au fonctionnaires de la police et de la
gendarmerie qu'à cette heure nous en
voulons mais à l'organisateur
de ce chaos
le ministre Darmanin qui devrait plutôt
baisser le nez avoir honte devant
l'échec absolu de ce qu'est sa mission
c'est l'État qui sait qu'il ne peut pas
négocier autrement que dans le rapport
de force et sa position c'est sa posture
quel que soit le gouvernement et le
régime politique d'ailleurs il ne sait
pas négocié dans le calme et la bonne
volonté il ne sait juste pas il a
attaqué directement depuis des années
des policiers gendarmes en disant qu'il
tuait qu'il mutilaient qu'ils étaient
des extrémistes ou parfois des fascistes
dans les organisations fascistes bon oui
il faut pas s'en prendre au policiers
aux gendarmes il vaut mieux s'en prendre
de politique donc actes c'est déjà mieux
Jean-Luc Mélenchon il est insoumise dans
les violences policières mais il est
soumis devant toutes les autres formes
de violence et vous savez pourquoi parce
que Jean-Luc Mélenchon et ses amis ce
sont les rentiers de la colère les
rentiers de la misère des petites gens
et sont les actionnaires de ces formes
de violence un parti politique sont en
train de faire sécession du champ
républicain quand ils ne prennent pas
plus largement la nuque toute la nuque
pas toute la Nupe mais aux élus je vois
d'ailleurs que au sein il y a beaucoup
de gènes d'une certaine façon par
rapport à ces positions qui sont des
positions
ultra radicales de l'ultra gauche même
tonalité en Allemagne qu'en France mega
grève aujourd'hui outre-Rhin un
mouvement unitaire des syndicats c'est
très rare dans le pays les transports
sont paralysés dans un contexte
d'inflation l'objectif et de réclamer
des hausses de salaire significatives
cette image en Israël ou une
manifestation très très importante à
rassembler des dizaines de milliers de
personnes hier soir à Tel-Aviv ainsi que
Jérusalem pour protester contre l'une
des réformes les plus radicales de
l'histoire du pays qui vise à renforcer
le pouvoir des élus sur les magistrats
une mobilisation qui ne fait que prendre
de l'ampleur depuis trois mois hier soir
le patron de la police de tel Aviva même
rejoint le mouvement défilant aux côtés
des manifestants avant d'être licenciés
dans la nuit avant goût de la dixième
journée de mobilisation contre la
réforme des retraites le trafic sera une
nouvelle fois très perturbé dans les
transports fait moins que lors des
précédentes de journées selon les
prévisions 4 TGV sur 5 2 ter et
Intercité sur 3 perturbations aussi dans
le métro parisien je crois que le
gouvernement doit changer de méthode
c'est à dire ne plus il a plus de
majorité on voit au Parlement
sur les partenaires sociaux pour les
prochains projets moi j'ai entendu le
président de la République vous l'avez
entendu puisque vous l'avez diffusé à
Bruxelles dire à Laurent Berger je tends
la main pour rencontrer l'intervatoire
mais il y a aussi des moments où il a
décidé d'être un peu moins sympa avec
leur en berger quand même et de le citer
énormément et de dire qu'il était en
minorité presque de l'humilier
je suis désolé de lui dire comme ça mais
elle est où la main tendue sur la
question des retraites c'est le sujet
actuel c'est celui dont on parle sur
pour parler du travail on a toujours été
là nous avons un désaccord sur la
manière d'équilibrer le système des
retraites nous avons des accords mais la
CFDT ne nie pas d'ailleurs qu'il faut
équilibrer le système des retraites et
ça les honore donc le sujet était mal
posé
bah je constate que l'expliquer je
constate que depuis que je m'intéresse
au sujet des retraites c'est assez
longtemps bien avant que je fasse de la
politique activement on n'a jamais
réussi à avoir un constat serein posé
sur ce débat et rediscutons et du
travail et des retraites et en mettant
de côté pour l'instant la réforme qui a
été adoptée je le rappelle par 403 qui
est pas validé qui est pas par le
Conseil et pas promulgué si c'est deux
sujets qui sont sur la table on va
discuter